We have a sub Reddit discussion forum where
you can join 26000 other viewers and listeners
and discuss politics respectfully. You can
find it at David Pakman dotcom slash Reddit.
Few notable posts I spotted this morning. One is
a user asking whether we are going to get to four
thousand daily deaths from the virus after
Christmas or New Year's. I've said before
that I believe the case peak is coming very
soon and that the death peak is slightly behind
that and that then we are going to start seeing
warming, weather and vaccinations starting to
have an impact probably by late January, early
February. So I believe we are almost at the
pandemic peak unless something goes very wrong. I
hope we don't get to four thousand daily deaths.
We are regularly seeing 3300, 3400 now, more
than a nine elevens worth of deaths every day.
It's it's conceivable we will get to four
thousand. I'm hopeful that we will not,
because that would be an absolutely a tragic,
tragic milestone. But it's not inconceivable,
another user of reminding us that New York has
enacted automatic voter registration. This is
a topic we've been discussing for a very long
time. The idea that in order to vote, you need
to do something beyond simply being a citizen
is antithetical to the way many voting systems
are set up in other countries. Undocumented
immigrants, by their nature, can't vote because
they're not citizens. This is not something that
is unique to the United States. And yet we have
this process here which serves only to dissuade
people from voting or prevent people from voting,
which is even though you could vote, you
can't vote unless you register to vote. Some
states allowing same day registration, many not
allowing it. New York state has enacted automatic
voter registration. The details are still being
sifted through, but that is very, very good news.
More states should do it. And then lastly,
because we're wrapping up here before the holiday,
we got a holiday greeting via the Subrata holiday.
Greetings to David and Pat with much. Thanks.
Thanks for maintaining continued surveillance
of the events of this past year, including
the horrendous covid pandemic and the equally
disgusting Trump and Republican machinations
revolving around the election. As someone who
is increasingly tuned out much of the news, I
nevertheless have great respect for those who can
face what's been going on and report and comment
about it. It's not an easy task. Knowledge can be
disheartening, but also empowering hope next year
ends on a higher note for all of us. But whatever
the case, I hope the Pakman show will endure a
beautiful message. And you can join the discussion
at David Pakman dot com slash. Read it. All right.